Teenage pregnancy is often talked about as a problem to be fixed. A mistake, a life ruined before it's even started. But those narratives rarely come from the people who've actually lived it. I'm Dr. Marianne, a clinical psychologist, and today I'm joined by Dr. Haley Lagasse, an educational psychologist who became a mother at the age of 15. We talk about what teenage mothers really need from families, professionals and systems and how judgment, stigma, and low expectations can actually do far more harm than the pregnancy itself. This conversation is about support, possibility, and what happens when we actually invest in people instead of writing them off.
青少年怀孕通常被视为一个需要解决的问题。一个错误，一个还没开始就被毁掉的人生。但这些叙述很少来自那些真正经历过的人。我是临床心理学家玛丽安博士，今天和我在一起的是教育心理学家海莉·拉加斯博士，她在15岁时就成为了母亲。我们讨论了青少年母亲真正需要家庭、专业人士和系统提供什么支持，以及评判、污名化和低期望实际上比怀孕本身造成的伤害要大得多。这次谈话的主题是支持、可能性，以及当我们真正投资于人而不是放弃他们时会发生什么。
I hope you find it so useful. And if you do, like and subscribe for more. Hi, I just want to welcome along to the podcast, Dr. Haley Lugasi, who is an educational psychologist. Welcome along, Haley. Thank you. Thanks for having me. Thanks for being here. And we are here because we want to tell a little bit about your story, but talk about how people can. and learn from your inspiring tale and the experiences you've been through, both kind of adverse and kind of positive. And, you know, we're leading with the fact that you became pregnant age 14 and had your baby age 15, your first child. Could you tell us a little bit about that,
希望你觉得这很有用。如果是这样，请点赞并订阅以获取更多内容。嗨，我想欢迎教育心理学家海莉·卢加西博士来到播客。欢迎你，海莉。谢谢。谢谢你邀请我。谢谢你的到来。我们在这里是因为我们想讲讲你的故事，并谈谈人们如何从你鼓舞人心的故事和你所经历的逆境与积极体验中学习。我们从你14岁怀孕，15岁生下第一个孩子这一事实开始。你能给我们讲讲那段经历吗，
please, Hayley? There's lots to tell. So I was living in Spain at the time as a young person, having moved there at the age of 10. I was born in Rhode in England originally. That was quite a big shift. It was a massive transition that came with lots of challenges. And I think part of the challenge led to me ultimately falling pregnant at quite a young age. Now whilst I was living in Spain at the time, I believed that the age of consent for sexual relationships was 13. And I was adamant that that was the case. I'm not quite sure now looking back whether that was the case or not. However, I didn't really understand what pregnancy meant. and I didn't really understand that having relations could lead to pregnancy.
海莉？有很多要说的。当时我住在西班牙，作为一个年轻人，我在10岁时搬到了那里。我最初出生在英国的罗德。那是一个很大的转变。这是一个伴随着许多挑战的巨大过渡。我认为部分挑战最终导致我在很年轻的时候就怀孕了。虽然当时我住在西班牙，但我认为性关系的同意年龄是13岁。我当时坚信情况就是这样。现在回想起来，我不确定事实是否如此。然而，我并不真正理解怀孕意味着什么，也不真正理解发生关系会导致怀孕。
So it certainly wasn't a planned pregnancy, and it certainly was something that was a shock when I realised when I found out what was actually happening. So I found myself in a relationship with a young man who was five years older than me, so he was 19 at the time, so overage. And we had been dating or seeing each other getting to know each other, for a couple of months before I fell pregnant. And I felt quite quickly that I was in love, as you do when you're a young person.
所以这肯定不是计划内的怀孕，当我意识到发生了什么时，这确实是一个打击。我当时和一个比我大五岁的年轻人谈恋爱，他当时19岁，已经成年了。在我们怀孕前，我们已经约会或交往、互相了解了几个月。我很快就坠入爱河，就像年轻人那样。
So I felt pregnant, yet didn't really understand that that's what was happening, that I was actually growing a child inside. The pregnancy itself was extremely challenging, partly because of my family's response, my mum's response in particular, who was living in Spain with me at the time, with me at the time. She found it extremely difficult to process and accept that her 14-year-old
所以我怀孕了，但并没有真正理解发生了什么，我实际上是在孕育一个孩子。怀孕本身极具挑战性，部分原因是家人的反应，特别是当时和我一起住在西班牙的母亲的反应。她发现很难处理和接受她14岁的
daughter was pregnant. Now in Spain, you have the right to make decisions about your body, regardless of how old you are. Similar to the UK, I believe. So I was able to decide whether or not I wanted to proceed with the pregnancy, whereas my mum was adamant that it was best for me to have an abortion. I declined, which was again really distressing for my mum because she truly believed that becoming a mum at such a young age was going to ruin my life and potentially ruin the child's life, you know, the child that was going to be born. So the early days, the early pregnancy days were particularly challenging that led to a lot of conflict within the home and that did ultimately lead to be moving out, so no longer living with my mum and moving in
女儿怀孕了。在西班牙，无论你多大，你都有权对自己的身体做出决定。我相信这和英国类似。所以我可以决定是否要继续怀孕，而我母亲坚决认为我最好堕胎。我拒绝了，这让我母亲非常痛苦，因为她真心认为在这么小的年纪当妈妈会毁了我的生活，并可能毁了孩子的生活，你知道，那个即将出生的孩子。所以怀孕初期的日子特别艰难，导致家里发生了很多冲突，最终导致我搬了出去，不再和母亲住在一起，而是搬到了
with my son's biological father. So the pregnancy itself was very high stress. not very well supported from my mum. My wider family were living in England at the time or elsewhere. I have a brother in Canada. And I think that public perceptions of teenage pregnancy are quite damaging to the person that is pregnant. And that's the case for me. I definitely found that even the professionals that were involved in my life were extremely judgmental at that time. I have this one particular memory of going to the doctors after declining the abortion.
我儿子的亲生父亲那里。所以怀孕本身压力非常大。我没有得到母亲很好的支持。我的其他家人当时住在英国或其他地方。我在加拿大有一个兄弟。我认为公众对青少年怀孕的看法对怀孕者是非常有害的。我的情况就是这样。我确实发现，即使是参与我生活的专业人士在当时也非常具有评判性。我特别记得在拒绝堕胎后去看医生。
and it was a clinical psychologist or equivalent in Spain and she shipped me off with a doll to look after for the weekend to pretend that it was a baby. And I just think looking back now, I think it's absolutely hilarious. Like what good would that do? Sending a doll, it didn't cry,
那是在西班牙的一位临床心理学家或类似职位的人，她给了我一个洋娃娃，让我周末照顾，假装那是婴儿。现在回想起来，我觉得这太搞笑了。那有什么用呢？送一个洋娃娃，它不会哭，
it didn't need nappy changes. It wasn't one of these quite advanced dolls that actually needs to be cared for. It was quite literally a doll. They were cram. I thought that was cute. So, yeah, the pregnancy was really, challenging. And then of course given birth at the age of 15. I mean I wouldn't wish that on
它不需要换尿布。它不是那种真正需要照顾的高级洋娃娃。它就是一个字面意义上的洋娃娃。他们很荒谬。我觉得这很可爱。所以，是的，怀孕真的很艰难。然后当然是在15岁时分娩。我的意思是，我不会希望任何人经历这些。
anybody. It was extremely difficult. One of the midwives was extremely judgmental of me whilst I was giving you know giving birth because I was crying and screaming and saying how horrible it was and how I wanted it to be over and he actually made a comment to me saying that I shouldn't have opened my legs in the first place and I wouldn't be in that position. And I think some people don't believe me when I say that. It genuinely, genuinely happened and it it shocks me that there were people out there that could treat somebody who's going through one of those difficult things they probably ever will in their lives and to say such a thing.
这极其困难。其中一位助产士在我分娩时对我非常评判，因为我在哭喊，说这有多可怕，我希望这一切快点结束，他竟然对我说，我当初就不该张开腿，就不会落到这个地步。我想有些人不相信我说的。这确实确实发生了，让我震惊的是，竟然有人能这样对待一个正在经历人生中最困难事情之一的人，并说出这样的话。
So hopefully that gives you a snapshot of what that experience was like. Absolutely. I mean, I'm so sorry to hear that that was your experience. And, you know, a woman who's in her 30s or her 40s often says, I want this to be over, you know, I don't want to do this anymore. And that's because it really hurts, you know? Yes. And I was really struck with empathy.
希望这能让你对那段经历有个大概的了解。当然。我的意思是，听到你的经历我感到非常抱歉。而且，你知道，一个30多岁或40多岁的女性经常说，我希望这一切结束，你知道，我不想再这样做了。那是因为这真的很痛，你知道吗？是的。我真的对你作为一名青少年母亲感到同情。
for you as a teenage mum, it was making me think about my experiences of my first pregnancy with my son, who's now 12. And it was a planned pregnancy, but I went along to the midwife clinic. I was very excited and, you know, all of that and, you know, any appointments had with my GP. And I would have been so very upset
这让我想起了我怀第一个儿子时的经历，他现在12岁了。那是一次计划内的怀孕，但我去了助产士诊所。我非常兴奋，你知道，所有这些，还有我和全科医生进行的任何预约。如果有人建议我堕胎，我会非常难过
and so very distressed if someone had suggested abortion with me because this is a baby that already feels like part of me and I've already, you know, looked at what size blueberry they are in the apps. And I already felt like a mother. And we can't assume that because a mother to be is young, that she's not also having those same psychological changes. And really, really hard, Haley. I'm so sorry that you experienced that.
和非常痛苦，因为这是一个已经感觉像是我一部分的婴儿，我已经，你知道，在应用程序上查过他们像蓝莓一样大。我已经感觉自己像个母亲了。我们不能因为准妈妈年轻，就认为她没有经历同样的心理变化。真的，真的很难，海莉。我很抱歉你经历了这些。
Hence I'm here, raising awareness, because I suppose part of my life goal is trying to change people's perceptions of people in general, but teenage parents is obviously people that matter a lot to me and trying to change the narrative about the outcomes for the children because I think there's so much focus on the negative sides and the downsides have been such a young parent and absolutely it's extremely challenging and outcomes can not be so good.
所以我在这里提高认识，因为我想我的人生目标的一部分是试图改变人们对人的普遍看法，但青少年父母显然是我非常关心的人，并试图改变关于孩子未来结果的叙述，因为我认为人们太关注年轻父母的负面和不利方面了，当然这极具挑战性，结果可能不太好。
But then that could be the same for a parent at any age. It doesn't matter just because you're in your 30s and it doesn't mean that you're going to have the best possible life will be able to give your child exactly what they need for the rest of their life. So I think that that narrative really needs shifting, hence I talk about my experience so much. Yeah, and we're probably going to focus more in on teenage mothers here today. But of course, we might cover teenage fathers as well. And if people are interested in learning more about teenage fathers,
但这对任何年龄的父母来说都是一样的。这并不重要，仅仅因为你30多岁，并不意味着你就会拥有最好的生活，或者能够为你的孩子提供他们余生所需的一切。所以我认为这种叙述真的需要改变，所以我经常谈论我的经历。是的，我们今天可能会更多地关注青少年母亲。但当然，我们也可能会谈到青少年父亲。如果人们有兴趣了解更多关于青少年父亲的信息，
there's a really great episode that I did previously on a project that's operating to support teen fathers, to optimally thrive as, as, you know, parents, really, not just as something that's shame-filled and, you know, should be covered up. So, yeah, please do check that out in the description or the show notes. But, you know, if we could have, you know, I guess people might be watching this for a variety of reasons. They might be a parent themselves, who's now got a teenage daughter, maybe who's pregnant, or someone that they care about who's pregnant. And they're seeking to understand.
我之前做过一期非常棒的节目，关于一个旨在支持青少年父亲的项目，让他们作为父母能够最优地成长，真的，不仅仅是把它当作一件充满羞耻、应该掩盖的事情。所以，是的，请务必在描述或节目说明中查看。但是，你知道，如果我们能，我想人们可能会因为各种原因观看这个节目。他们可能自己就是父母，现在有一个怀孕的十几岁女儿，或者他们关心的人怀孕了。他们正在寻求理解。
Or they might be working in mental health and kind of, wondering how to support people or how to speak about them respectfully. What would be useful for us to share at this point, I guess, Haley, for whoever's watching? That's a really good question. Really good question. I think for me the most important thing would be that whilst finding out that your daughter at a very young age is pregnant can be extremely distressing for you, I think it's extremely important to acknowledge those feelings and sit with them as much as you need to, but to not forget that your daughter is most likely also finding this extremely challenging.
或者他们可能在心理健康领域工作，想知道如何支持人们或如何尊重地谈论他们。海莉，对于正在观看的人，我们现在分享什么会有用呢？这是一个非常好的问题。真的很好的问题。对我来说，最重要的一点是，虽然发现你十几岁的女儿怀孕可能会让你感到极度痛苦，但我认为承认这些感受并尽可能地去面对它们非常重要，但不要忘记你的女儿很可能也觉得这极具挑战性。
Whether it was a planned pregnancy or not, in my instance it was not a planned pregnancy, so I had the shock of finding out that I was pregnant, whereas I know that there were some young ladies out there that do plan on having babies at a very young age. But regardless, it's a very difficult thing for them to go through. And when you're pregnant, you know, those of us that have had children, we know how challenging it is, all our hormones are going crazy, we're feeling emotional, we might be experiencing morning sickness and all these other symptoms, I guess, of pregnancy. And the most useful thing for me in that moment would have been to have
无论这是否是计划内的怀孕，在我的例子中这不是计划内的怀孕，所以我经历了发现自己怀孕的震惊，而我知道有些年轻女士确实计划在很年轻的时候生孩子。但无论如何，这对她们来说都是一件非常困难的事情。当你怀孕时，你知道，我们这些生过孩子的人都知道这有多么挑战，我们所有的荷尔蒙都在疯狂波动，我们感到情绪化，我们可能会经历晨吐和所有这些怀孕的其他症状。在那一刻，对我来说最有用的事情就是
had a supportive parent, a parent that put her own feelings aside, for me, it was just my mom, if she could have put her own feelings aside, had her moments, cried, screamed, you know, have done whatever she needed to do with her support network, and then to have supported me and understood, is the way that it's going to be, it's not going to be easy, but I'm going to be with you. I'm going to walk alongside you. I'm going to guide you. I'm going to mentor you the best that I can, and we will get through this together. I think that that's likely to support better outcomes for both the mum and the child rather than pushing your daughter away. And that's, I think, where I get most distress is when I see mums or parents pushing their daughter away because they
有一个支持性的父母，一个能把自己的感受放在一边的父母，对我来说，那只是我妈妈，如果她能把自己的感受放在一边，有她自己的时刻，哭泣，尖叫，你知道，用她的支持网络做她需要做的任何事情，然后支持我并理解，这就是现实，这不会容易，但我会和你在一起。我会陪着你。我会引导你。我会尽我所能指导你，我们会一起度过难关。我认为这比把女儿推开更有可能支持母亲和孩子获得更好的结果。这就是我认为最让我痛苦的地方，当我看到母亲或父母因为女儿
fallen pregnant because actually they're less likely to receive the right support and therefore the outcomes could not be so great. Yeah, and I think I was thinking about the term of what we talk about in psychology as containment. So yeah, like you might not be thrilled about it and you might even share some of that with your daughter and kind of be honest, this is a real shock. But it's not hopefully done from a position of crossness and that, you know, there's not massive amounts of distress after the initial news, you know, it's going to take a while to adjust initially, I guess. But really, if you're not managing that, it shouldn't just be your daughter that's getting that and seeing that. You know, like you said, it might be that you've got your own
怀孕而把她推开时，因为实际上她们获得正确支持的可能性降低了，因此结果可能不会那么好。是的，我想到了我们在心理学中谈论的“容纳”这个词。所以，是的，你可能对此并不感到兴奋，你甚至可能和你的女儿分享其中的一些感受，并诚实地说，这真是一个打击。但希望这并不是出于愤怒，你知道，在最初的消息之后，并没有大量的痛苦，你知道，最初需要一段时间来适应，我想。但真的，如果你不能处理好这一点，不应该只有你的女儿在承受和看到这些。你知道，就像你说的，可能你有自己的
parents around your friends, you know, maybe your siblings, maybe reaching out for, you know, discussions with someone that's qualified to support you to explore this, maybe even any local organisations who do support teenage mothers or people that have got kind of families that don't look typical. Yeah, like it shouldn't just be the daughter's responsibility to soak all that up. No. And you know, the daughter's going to have a lot in their mind. So I think as much as the parents can do to support would, you know, it would go down really well. I think also important to mention is that we tend to fixate on the what could go wrong and the negatives. And the negatives, And we tend to, I think, catastrophize the future outcomes
父母、朋友，你知道，也许是你的兄弟姐妹，也许是向有资格支持你的人寻求讨论，去探索这一点，甚至可能是任何支持青少年母亲或家庭看起来不典型的当地组织。是的，这不应该只是女儿的责任去承受这一切。不。而且你知道，女儿脑子里会有很多事情。所以我认为父母能做的支持越多，你知道，效果会非常好。我认为同样重要的是要提到，我们倾向于盯着可能出错的地方和负面因素。我们倾向于，我认为，把未来的结果灾难化
for both the mother and the child. But actually, there are so many stories of young parents, young mums that have gone on to do extremely well. They've been great parents. They've raised, you know, successful, healthy, happy children that have gone on into adulthood and done very well. So I think it's really important to try not to think in the most negative way and try to reframe the way
对母亲和孩子都是如此。但实际上，有太多的年轻父母、年轻妈妈的故事，她们后来做得非常好。她们是伟大的父母。她们抚养了，你知道，成功、健康、快乐的孩子，他们长大成人并做得很好。所以我认为尝试不要以最消极的方式思考，并尝试重构你的思维方式非常重要
that you're thinking if you're automatically going to, oh my goodness, you're ruining your life. absolutely not. Is it going to be a little bit challenging initially? Most likely, are you going to potentially have to put on pause some of your dreams and hopes? Probably, yes, just like I had to. But that doesn't mean that you then can't come back to those a little bit later in life when you're ready to. And alongside that, you're going to have the joy of being a parent. So for me, it's been a really beautiful experience. Extremely challenging. Yes. Would I have done it differently if I would have known better? Potentially, but those weren't the circumstances that I found
如果你自动想到，天哪，你毁了你的生活。绝对不是。起初会有一点挑战吗？很有可能，你是否可能不得不暂停你的一些梦想和希望？可能，是的，就像我不得不做的那样。但这并不意味着当你准备好后，以后就不能回到那些梦想中去。除此之外，你还将拥有为人父母的快乐。所以对我来说，这是一次非常美好的经历。极具挑战性。是的。如果我早知道，我会做得不同吗？有可能，但那不是我所处的环境
myself in. So yeah, try to change the narrative, I guess, for yourself about the future. Yeah, let's focus on the positives, you know. Hopefully you've enjoyed being a parent and now you've got your daughter who is now pregnant. But yeah, it's not, it doesn't always need to be from a position of lack, does it? And actually, you know, having worked with a lot of families where babies have turned up unexpectedly, that child has really been a great joy. to the families, to the extended families, you know, grandparents got to become grandparents sooner than expected and, you know, been around in better health to be able to enjoy them as well. Like it's not all, it's not all negative. Obviously children are not free. Mine are really
所以我发现自己处于那种境地。所以是的，尝试为你自己改变关于未来的叙述。是的，让我们关注积极的一面，你知道。希望你一直享受为人父母的快乐，现在你有了女儿，她现在怀孕了。但是，是的，它并不总是需要从匮乏的角度出发，不是吗？实际上，你知道，在与许多意外怀孕的家庭合作时，那个孩子确实给家庭、给大家庭带来了巨大的快乐，祖父母比预期更早地成为了祖父母，而且，你知道，身体状况更好，能够享受他们。就像它不是全部，它不是全部负面的。显然孩子不是免费的。我的孩子真的很
expensive. Yeah, same, same. So that is tricky and I think certainly having grown up in England, a lot of the narrative around teenage pregnancies was kind of, you know, living on benefits, getting a council house, it was never thought of as a positive thing. And I think there was lots of shame, lots of blame, lots of stigma. How was that for you in Spain? Great question. So Spain, again, we are talking 17 years ago when this happens. So things may have shifted.
昂贵。是的，一样，一样。所以这很棘手，而且我肯定在英国长大，关于青少年怀孕的很多叙述都是，你知道，靠福利生活，住政府公房，它从来没有被认为是一件积极的事情。而且我认为有很多羞耻，很多指责，很多污名。你在西班牙时感觉如何？好问题。所以西班牙，我们谈论的是17年前发生的事情。所以情况可能已经改变了。
In Spain, the benefit system is very, very different. So when I found myself pregnant, we were already struggling financially, significantly. I would describe ourselves as living in quite a significant. extreme poverty at the time. So of course, falling pregnant definitely brought added stress because of the cost. There is no benefit system whereby you can get, for example, housing benefits, support you to find a place to live, and even things like support to eat on a daily basis. There wasn't a benefit for that, for example, like a living benefit. So we had to very much rely on the churches that would give out boxes of food, as well as food banks that were in the local area. And often,
在西班牙，福利制度非常、非常不同。所以当我发现自己怀孕时，我们在经济上已经非常、非常挣扎了。我会形容我们当时生活在相当严重的极端贫困中。所以当然，怀孕肯定带来了额外的压力，因为费用问题。没有福利制度可以让你，例如，获得住房福利，支持你找到住的地方，甚至像每天吃饭的支持。例如，没有那样的福利，比如生活福利。所以我们必须非常依赖教会发放的食物盒，以及当地的食物银行。而且通常，
those didn't come with the right foods that we needed, even things like formula, for example. I was able to breastfeed for the first four months, but then we moved on to formula, and we could not afford formula. So we very much had to rely on the generosity of the churches, the food banks, and often go hungry myself to make sure that the little one was fed. So that was a significant challenge, and that I guess is something that people do need to be very mindful of. It did get to a point, unfortunately, in my situation where I did find myself having to steal and find ways of making money that I wouldn't do now, because you do what you have to do when you're a parent. You have so much love for your child that you will do anything to make sure they're fed.
那些并没有提供我们需要的正确食物，甚至像配方奶粉，例如。我前四个月能够母乳喂养，但后来我们改用配方奶粉，我们买不起配方奶粉。所以我们非常依赖教会、食物银行的慷慨，而且我经常自己挨饿，以确保小家伙有饭吃。所以这是一个重大的挑战，我想这是人们确实需要非常注意的事情。不幸的是，在我的情况下，确实到了我不得不偷窃并寻找赚钱方式的地步，我现在不会那样做了，因为当你为人父母时，你会做你必须做的事。你对你的孩子有那么多的爱，你会做任何事来确保他们有饭吃。
So yeah, very, very different to here. I returned to England when my son was two, and I was extremely grateful to be able to come back and receive the benefit support that I desperately needed to help me progress with my life. Even something like, for example, being able to return to education, I left school with no GCSEs. So I had no prospects, I had no future at that time. You know, potentially would have even struggled to get a job in a shop, for example, because of my social skills at that time.
所以是的，和这里非常、非常不同。我儿子两岁时我回到了英国，我非常感激能够回来并获得我迫切需要的福利支持，以帮助我改善生活。甚至像，例如，能够重返教育，我离开学校时没有任何GCSE成绩。所以我当时没有任何前景，没有任何未来。你知道，甚至可能因为我当时的社交技能而难以找到一份商店的工作，例如。
But the government system, the benefit system, enabled me to go back to college to start getting my qualifications and they funded a nursery place for my little boy. And I didn't have to pay a penny. And on top of that, they contributed to pay for my flat that I lived in through housing benefit. So looking at where I am today now, working as an educational psychologist, I actually have a lot of gratitude to the UK benefit system for enabling me to make steps towards my future. And I think it's thinking about not just the person you are now as a 14-year-old mother. and ultimately when you came to the UK, a 16-year-old mother, we're investing in the future Dr. Haley Lagassee, right?
但是政府系统、福利系统使我能够回到学院开始获得我的资格证书，他们为我的小男孩资助了一个托儿所名额。我一分钱都不用付。最重要的是，他们通过住房福利为我居住的公寓支付了部分费用。所以看看我今天在哪里，作为一名教育心理学家，我实际上对英国的福利制度充满感激，因为它使我能够朝着未来迈出步伐。而且我认为这不仅仅是考虑你现在作为一个14岁的母亲。而且最终当你来到英国时，一个16岁的母亲，我们是在投资未来，海莉·拉加斯博士，对吧？
Because actually now you are fully kind of, you know, paying tax and part of society. And, you know, you're a consumer. And that cannot be underestimated. If we support people well, they give back into the system. And, you know, with your work supporting children, young people, schools and families, you are giving back in abundance.
因为实际上现在你已经完全，你知道，在纳税并成为社会的一部分。而且，你知道，你是一个消费者。这不能被低估。如果我们很好地支持人们，他们就会回馈系统。而且，你知道，通过你支持儿童、年轻人、学校和家庭的工作，你正在给予丰厚的回报。
So let's let's not forget about that too. Absolutely agree. I'm so glad that you said that. But yes, absolutely. Let's invest in people. And as I said, I have so much gratitude. And I feel a real responsibility to give back and to talk about the positives that this country has given me
所以让我们也不要忘记这一点。绝对同意。我很高兴你这么说。但是是的，绝对。让我们投资于人。正如我所说，我充满感激。我感到有一种真正的责任去回馈，去谈论这个国家给我的积极方面
because I wouldn't be where I am today. And I am in such a great place today. And that's, you know, thanks to all of the support that was offered, not just financially, but emotionally, all of the support services that were available, like Schwartzat Centre's back when they were quite common. And I'm so extremely thankful to everybody that now I want to be contributing and giving back. And I really hope that people can see that and start to change the way they're seeing things. Invest in people, they do give back.
因为我不会有今天的成就。而且我今天处于一个非常好的位置。这要归功于所提供的所有支持，不仅是经济上的，还有情感上的，所有可用的支持服务，比如Schwartzat中心，当它们还很普遍的时候。我非常感谢每一个人，现在我想做出贡献并回馈社会。我真的希望人们能看到这一点，并开始改变他们看待事物的方式。投资于人，他们确实会回馈。
Yeah, I'm going to ask you a question now. It might be that we need to pause the recording whilst we have a think about it. Or you might be like, no, I know the answer already. But if we were to kind of think about UK landscape now, we've got a 14-year-old teenage mother who's decided she wants to keep her baby, what could we put in place or what would be an ideal gold standard experience for her, for her and her baby, who she's growing still currently, to thrive. And if we need to pause for a moment, that's absolutely okay. but I really would like to think about what a gold standard would look like. That's a really good question. I'm going to do that thing where I say that I think it would be context dependent
是的，我现在要问你一个问题。可能我们需要暂停录音来思考一下。或者你可能会说，不，我已经知道答案了。但如果我们思考一下现在的英国环境，我们有一个14岁的青少年母亲，她决定想要留下她的孩子，我们可以采取什么措施，或者对她和她目前仍在孕育的孩子来说，什么是理想的黄金标准体验，让他们茁壮成长。如果我们确实需要暂停一下，那完全没问题。但我真的很想思考一下黄金标准会是什么样子。这是一个非常好的问题。我会做那件事，我会说我认为这将取决于具体情况
and I think it will very much depend on the brother and what their circumstances are. I think it would be very different for a 14-year-old young lady who's fallen pregnant and has got a really large, very supportive family, you know, perhaps two parents, you know, who are going to be the grandparents that would be able to help look after the baby so that she could continue with education. And so I think that perhaps the support that she needs is going to be very different to somebody like me who's only maybe got one parent or no contact really with their families, living in poverty. Maybe they've got additional needs and really struggle educationally. So I don't think that there is one gold standard that would be, you know, it's not one size fits all.
而且我认为这很大程度上取决于这个女孩以及她们的情况。我认为对于一个怀孕并拥有一个非常庞大、非常支持的家庭的14岁年轻女士来说，这会非常不同，你知道，也许有两个父母，你知道，他们将成为祖父母，能够帮助照顾孩子，这样她就可以继续接受教育。所以我认为她需要的支持可能与像我这样可能只有一个父母或与家人几乎没有联系、生活在贫困中的人非常不同。也许她们有额外的需求，在教育上真的很挣扎。所以我认为没有一个黄金标准，你知道，它不是一刀切的。
I think that for me personally, it's all down to ensuring that that young mum continues to have access to education, has access to a, support network, whether that's family or whether that is professional, or professional supporting them to develop their own non-professional support network, and supporting them to, you know, think about the future, learn about things that they may not know about in terms of being a parent, support them with life skills, practical skills, managing money, things that we don't really think about that are really important when you become a parent. So bring it kind of, putting that into their package, I suppose, which I don't think the education system currently, does very well. But yes, as I've said, I think it will be really context dependent.
我认为对我个人而言，这一切都归结于确保那位年轻妈妈继续有机会接受教育，有机会获得支持网络，无论是家庭还是专业人士，或者专业人士支持她们发展自己的非专业支持网络，并支持她们，你知道，思考未来，学习关于为人父母方面她们可能不知道的事情，支持她们掌握生活技能、实践技能、理财，这些我们不太考虑但在你成为父母时非常重要的事情。所以把这些带入她们的方案中，我想，我认为教育系统目前做得不是很好。但是是的，正如我所说，我认为这真的会取决于具体情况。
Yeah, thank you for that. And I did throw that as a bit of a curveball. But I think I would also want her to have a dedicated, safe, non-judgmental mentor, really, to see her through from wherever she is now to the first two or three years, maybe even the first five years of her baby's life. And that might be a mummy. It might be another female. It might be a man, I don't know, but someone that has got a really good heart that is going to give her that space to to thrive, but also share some of her vulnerabilities and kind of be there toe for toe. And maybe sometimes they happen in the, you know, I remember when I had a health visitor coming and kind of, you know, watching me with my child.
是的，谢谢你。我确实抛出了一个有点棘手的问题。但我还希望她能有一个专注、安全、不带评判的导师，真的，从她现在的处境一直陪伴她到孩子出生后的前两三年，甚至前五年。那可能是一位妈妈。可能是另一位女性。可能是位男士，我不知道，但必须是一个心地善良的人，会给她空间去茁壮成长，但也分享她的一些脆弱，并真正地陪伴她。也许有时他们会出现在，你知道，我记得当我有健康访视员来的时候，你知道，看着我和我的孩子。
And maybe there's some element of that as well. But actually some element of just let's go for a cup of tea and see how you are and what's feeling hard right now. and, you know, that would be a really lovely addition. I think that would be absolutely wonderful. And that's, I suppose, what I kind of felt from the staff at the Shaw Start Centre when I did return. It was, although they weren't dedicated to me, because of the amount of times that I spent there, I developed really lovely relationships with the staff.
也许也有这方面的因素。但实际上，只是去喝杯茶，看看你怎么样，现在感觉什么比较困难。而且，你知道，那将是一个非常可爱的补充。我认为那绝对会很棒。而且我想，这就是我在回到Shaw Start中心时从工作人员那里感受到的。虽然他们不是专门为我服务的，但因为我花在那里的时间很多，我和工作人员建立了非常可爱的关系。
And it was, you know, the same staff there consistently. And I could just pop in and have the non-judgmental conversations. I could go and say, gosh, this is absolutely exhausting. I don't think I can continue doing this. But they also have the knowledge and skill to be able to help me and tell me and explain how to do things differently. And I really respected them for that. I didn't feel like they were there judging me. I didn't feel like they were coming to check on my baby's weight or are they, you know, is your little boy eating enough? So I think that's potentially a challenge with health
而且，你知道，那里是同样的工作人员。我可以随时进去进行不带评判的谈话。我可以去说，天哪，这太让人精疲力竭了。我不认为我能继续这样做了。但他们也有知识和技能来帮助我，告诉我并解释如何以不同的方式做事。我真的很尊重他们。我觉得他们不是在那里评判我。我觉得他们不是来检查我孩子的体重，或者他们，你知道，你的小男孩吃得够不够？所以我认为这可能是健康访视员的一个挑战
visitors is that I, you know, from my second child, who's now seven, definitely felt that when they came around, although they were lovely, there was an element of checking, you know, checking the house, checking the weight is, is everything being done as it should. We know that safeguarding was on their mind. If we could slightly remove that, then I feel that the relationships could be a lot better for the for the mum and baby. Yeah, and also you need, you know, it was really hard. My eldest woke up like 31 times a night when he was at his worst. Really hard, you know, I was just bone cold, like my bones felt cold because I was so tired. And I was more emotional because I was just so exhausted. And so if I went to a mum and baby group and had a particularly hard night,
因为我，你知道，对于我的第二个孩子，他现在七岁了，当他们过来时，我肯定感觉到了，虽然他们很可爱，但有一种检查的成分，你知道，检查房子，检查体重，一切是否按应有的方式进行。我们知道保障措施在他们的脑海中。如果我们能稍微消除这一点，那么我觉得对于妈妈和孩子来说，关系会好得多。是的，而且你需要，你知道，这真的很困难。我的大儿子在他最糟糕的时候晚上醒来31次。真的很困难，你知道，我骨子里都冷，因为我太累了。而且我更情绪化，因为我太精疲力竭了。所以如果我去参加妈妈和宝宝小组，经历了一个特别艰难的夜晚，
I might well be in tears. It's really hard. It's really hard. But at no point did anyone ever say, do you want to give your child up for adoption? But, you know, I think a young mum experiencing some of the same things is more likely to have that question asked to her. But that's not what she's saying necessarily. She might be saying that. Maybe you can support her to explore options. But also, she's just looking for validation. This is the hardest thing I've ever done. Yeah. And I don't think it should matter how old you are. I think as you said, regardless of how old you are when you have your first child, second child, third child, it's exhausting and each baby is different. You know, I waited for nine years until I had my second child because it was so hard and due to circumstances. And I thought that it would be an absolute breeze. And no, it's been equally as difficult for different reasons. So yeah, just having somebody there that can just listen to you, make you a cup of tea, offer to hold the baby. come and do a bit of washing up for you. Just those nice practical supports would be so, so beneficial.
我很有可能会流泪。这真的很难。这真的很难。但从来没有人说过，你想把你的孩子送去领养吗？但是，你知道，我认为一个经历同样事情的年轻妈妈更有可能被问到这个问题。但那不一定就是她想说的。她可能是在说那个。也许你可以支持她去探索选择。但是，她只是在寻求认可。这是我做过的最困难的事情。是的。而且我认为你多大并不重要。我认为正如你所说，无论你在生第一个孩子、第二个孩子、第三个孩子时多大，这都是精疲力竭的，每个婴儿都是不同的。你知道，我等了九年才生第二个孩子，因为这太难了，而且由于环境原因。我以为这会是一件轻而易举的事。不，由于不同的原因，它同样困难。所以是的，只要有某人在那里，能听你倾诉，为你泡杯茶，主动提出抱抱孩子。过来帮你洗点碗。仅仅是那些好的实际支持就会非常有益。
To all mums, but particularly young mums. Absolutely. I wish I'd had someone to come around and hold my baby because I've got another friend also called Marianne. I don't think she'll mind me calling her out on this. But we, when our children, our first babies were little, we'd go swimming together. And genuinely, we'd take all of our shower gels,
对所有妈妈，特别是年轻妈妈。绝对。我希望有人能过来抱抱我的孩子，因为我有另一个朋友也叫玛丽安。我不认为她介意我提到她。但是我们，当我们的孩子，我们的第一个宝宝还小的时候，我们会一起去游泳。而且真的，我们会带上我们所有的沐浴露，
we'd take our shampoo and our conditioner and our body puff and our razors. And we would poolside have our only shower that week. And we called it our spa. But our kids would be sat on the floor and would be fully showering and together side by side, like with people swimming up and down the electric. But we cannot have been the only moms in the country to be doing that. But what I've learned is showers and being clean and having clean hair. help me feel more put together and help me manage everything.
我们会带上我们的洗发水和护发素，我们的沐浴球和剃须刀。我们会在池边洗我们那周唯一的一次澡。我们称之为我们的水疗中心。但我们的孩子会坐在地板上，我们会一起洗澡，并肩而行，就像人们在电泳池里游来游去一样。但我们不可能是全国唯一这样做妈妈。但我学到的是，洗澡、保持干净、头发干净。帮助我感觉更从容，帮助我管理一切。
So I wish someone had supported me to bathe more often, which sound ridiculous, but actually that would have helped my bones to warm up and for me to feel like I didn't look such a state. I remember I was in a supermarket and I'd seen a leaflet a few days ago about life insurance. And I think at the time I was 32, maybe 33. And they said, oh, do you mean I over 50?
所以我希望有人能支持我更频繁地洗澡，这听起来很荒谬，但实际上这会帮助我的骨头变暖，让我感觉自己看起来没有那么糟糕。我记得我在超市里，几天前我看到了一份关于人寿保险的传单。我想当时我32岁，也许33岁。他们说，哦，你是说50岁以上吗？
over 50 plan and I was like, no. Like, like how not put together I was looking in my jumble sale outfit, whatever it was, but just let's support mothers to have a chance of of optimally thriving. Yeah, yeah, absolutely. Make them food. I think that's one of really, really practical ones, especially when you're a teenage mum and potentially haven't yet learn how to cook, which was definitely the case for me. I knew how to wash, close to a certain extent. But as I, you know, I mentioned those life skills, I think when you become a mum in your 20s or 30s, you've already potentially developed some of those life skills, you might be living on your own, know a little bit more about money and so on, whereas when you
50岁以上计划，我说，不。就像我穿着旧货店买的衣服看起来有多么不从容，无论那是什么，但让我们支持母亲们有机会最优地成长。是的，是的，绝对。给她们做饭。我认为这是非常、非常实际的事情之一，特别是当你是一个青少年妈妈，可能还没有学会如何做饭时，我当时的情况绝对是这样。我知道如何洗衣服，在一定程度上。但正如我，你知道，我提到了那些生活技能，我认为当你20多岁或30多岁成为妈妈时，你可能已经发展了一些生活技能，你可能独自生活，对金钱等了解多一点，而当你
are 14, 15, 16, and you still maybe not quite learn how to cook or how to navigate particular things around the house, that's where that practical support is so beneficial. So yeah, let's bring those in, bring more of that. Absolutely. So let's talk briefly about your kind of your dedication and your striving to become a psychologist. I know from before we hit record that your passion for that was ignited with some psychologist work that you'd received in Spain. Yes. Yeah, absolutely. So I had a bit of involvement from a school psychologist in Spain. So they're psychologists that are based within school settings and support children for a variety of reasons. The reasons that I had involvement were due to some difficult experiences that I had
14、15、16岁时，你可能还没有完全学会如何做饭或如何处理家里特定的事情，这就是那种实际支持非常有益的地方。所以是的，让我们把这些带进来，带来更多这样的支持。绝对。所以让我们简要谈谈你那种致力于成为心理学家的奉献和努力。我知道在录音前，你对心理学的热情是被你在西班牙接受的一些心理学家工作所点燃的。是的。是的，绝对。所以我当时在西班牙受到了一位学校心理学家的参与。所以他们是基于学校环境的心理学家，出于各种原因支持孩子。我参与的原因是因为我经历了一些困难的经历
whilst I was living in Spain. And one day as I was leaving the last session that I was having with her, she kind of shouted over to me, Haley, one day you'd make an exceptional psychologist. And at the time, I kind of brushed it off and thought, yes, whatever, I don't really care about this. Because I was really adamant, I wanted to be a writer, and I had lots of other passions.
当我在西班牙生活时。有一天，当我离开与她的最后一次会议时，她对我喊道，海莉，有一天你会成为一名出色的心理学家。当时，我有点不以为然，心想，是的，随便吧，我不在乎这个。因为我非常坚决，我想成为一名作家，我还有很多其他的热情。
However, that really stuck with me, and I'd always been very passionate about supporting children and young people, and I was known within my community for standing up to the bullies. I was a bit of a fighter at school, but not, I wouldn't initiate the fights. People would come to me because they knew that I would stand up for them and be an advocate for them. So I think as I was going through my really challenging times, I started to reflect on how I didn't want any other young people to experience the things that I'd experienced. So that's where I discovered this passion for becoming a psychologist.
然而，那真的留在了我的心里，我一直对支持儿童和年轻人充满热情，我在社区里以敢于对抗欺凌者而闻名。我在学校里有点像个斗士，但我不会主动发起战斗。人们会来找我，因为他们知道我会为他们挺身而出，成为他们的倡导者。所以我认为当我经历那些非常艰难的时期时，我开始反思我不希望任何其他年轻人经历我所经历的事情。所以这就是我发现成为心理学家的热情所在。
I wasn't entirely sure what type. I didn't really understand that there were lots of different areas to go into when it comes to psychology. And it's then when I came back to England, when I was 17 years old, I started really looking into it. But people didn't believe that I was going to be capable of becoming a psychologist. Because it is quite hard. It does take time. You do have to go to university. And when you've been a young parent and when you've left school at the age of 14 and you have no qualifications, no job experience, then everything is much more difficult.
我不完全确定是什么类型。我并不真正理解心理学有很多不同的领域可以进入。然后当我17岁回到英国时，我开始真正研究它。但人们不相信我有能力成为一名心理学家。因为它确实很难。它确实需要时间。你确实必须上大学。当你是一个年轻的父母，当你14岁离开学校，没有任何资格证书，没有任何工作经验时，那么一切都困难得多。
And I do remember going into a careers advice centre when I first came back to the UK when I was 17. and saying, I'd quite like to be a psychologist, without really knowing much more than that at that point. And she tried to encourage me to become a hairdresser instead because hair dressing is much easier to get into. You didn't need qualifications for it. I could do an apprenticeship or whatever. And she told me that it would take a very long time
我确实记得当我17岁刚回到英国时，我走进了一个职业咨询中心。说，我想成为一名心理学家，当时除了那个之外我真的不知道更多了。她试图鼓励我改做理发师，因为理发更容易进入。你不需要资格证书。我可以做学徒什么的。她告诉我那需要很长时间
and it's very competitive and very academic. Essentially, she was saying that she didn't believe that I would be capable. Because I was a young parent, I was single mom at that point, and obviously had no qualifications. So my dreams at that moment were completely destroyed and I did go and try hairdressing. Her dressing was not for me. I love hairdressers.
那里竞争非常激烈，学术氛围也很浓。本质上，她是在说她不相信我有能力做到。因为我当时是个年轻的母亲，还是个单亲妈妈，显然没有任何资历。所以那一刻我的梦想彻底破灭了，我确实去尝试了美发。美发不适合我。我很尊重美发师。
I have a lot of respect to them. It was not the right job for me. I simply could not get on with it. So I spent a few years feeling quite disheartened, not really knowing where to go, what to do with my life, because people had shut me down. But I did have this internal dream
我对他们非常尊重。但那不是适合我的工作。我实在无法适应。所以我度过了几年非常沮丧的时光，真的不知道该去哪里，该拿我的生活怎么办，因为人们否定了我。但我内心确实有一个梦想，
to be a psychologist of some type and help people. And it was then several years later, that I, by that point, met my now husband, and he was the person that really strongly advocated that I studied psychology. He felt that it would fulfill me and that my life would completely change rather than feeling so stuck. And that's when I really felt that, yes, actually, I could look at doing this. I can look at studying online, which I did my degree with the Open University. And I also felt that it would be really inspiring and powerful for my little boy to see so that by the time he became 18 he'd be able to say actually my
想成为某种心理学家并帮助他人。几年后，我遇到了现在的丈夫，是他强烈建议我学习心理学。他觉得这会让我感到充实，我的生活会彻底改变，而不是感到如此受困。就在那时，我真的觉得，是的，其实我可以考虑这样做。我可以考虑在线学习，我是在开放大学完成学位的。我也觉得这对我儿子来说会是非常鼓舞人心和强大的榜样，这样等他长到18岁时，他就能说，其实我的
mum had worked really hard to give me a better life and to better herself so that's the short story of yeah my dreams to become a psychologist and the hard work that needed to go into it amazing but what if that first careers advisor had had given you the support and encouragement that your now husband did you know because that actually would have really sped up the journey for you and would have validated that rather than dismissing and disparaging your dreams and shooting you down? Yeah. Yeah.
妈妈为了给我更好的生活和提升自己付出了巨大的努力。这就是我梦想成为心理学家的简短故事，以及为此付出的艰辛努力。太棒了，但如果那位最初的职业顾问给了你像你现在的丈夫那样的支持和鼓励呢？因为那实际上会大大加快你的进程，并会认可你的梦想，而不是否定、贬低并打击你？是的，确实如此。
I think that things could have been very, very different. I think that I could have had a couple of years where I wasn't as lost and didn't feel so terrible about myself because I was essentially believing what she'd said that I wasn't capable, that I wasn't good enough, I wasn't clever enough, all of those not very nice things that she shared. So life would have been very different in that sense.
我认为事情可能会有非常、非常大的不同。我想我可能不会有那几年迷茫的时光，也不会对自己感觉那么糟糕，因为我当时基本上相信了她所说的话，认为我没有能力，我不够好，我不够聪明，以及她所说的所有那些不友善的话。所以从那个意义上说，生活会大不相同。
But also, if she would have supported me to find the way, then I think I would have had perhaps a more normal, not normal, but maybe more typical study experience. So for example, I could have gone to college, I would have attained my GCSEs, perhaps then I would have gone to college and done A-levels, and then perhaps I could have gone to a university in person to complete my degree. Whereas instead, I found myself not doing A-levels at all,
但同时，如果她能支持我找到方向，我想我可能会有更正常的——也不是说正常，而是更典型的学习经历。例如，我可以去上学院，我会获得GCSE证书，也许然后我会去学院读A-level课程，接着也许我可以去大学实地完成我的学位。然而相反，我发现自己根本没有读A-level，
jumping straight to an open university degree, And as much as I'm extremely thankful for the open university and I owe them an awful and awful lot, I definitely missed out on having the experience of going to university. I always struggled to make friends because being a young mum and making friends can be extremely challenging. And I always felt very isolated and different from other people my age. And that wasn't helped by the fact that I was then doing everything remotely. Whilst also working, I had to have a full-time job to pay the bills, whilst also trying to be a mum, and then obviously a student at night.
而是直接跳到了开放大学的学位。尽管我非常感谢开放大学，我欠他们太多太多，但我确实错过了去大学校园的体验。我总是很难交到朋友，因为作为一个年轻妈妈，交朋友可能极具挑战性。我总是感到非常孤立，与同龄人不同。而且我当时所有事情都是远程完成的，这让情况更糟。在工作的同时，我必须有一份全职工作来支付账单，同时还要努力做一个母亲，晚上还要做一个学生。
I spend every single evening as soon as my little boy went to bed with my laptop studying. So it was absolutely exhausting, and I do believe that it didn't need to be that difficult. That if that person would have been kinder and would have supported me, then I feel that I could have one got to becoming a qualified psychologist sooner, but also enjoyed the journey a lot more. Whereas for me the journey was not enjoyable. I've only just started enjoying life the last three, four years since I've qualified. Yeah, and I think if people are watching or listening to this episode and they're like, right, okay, now what next?
我每天晚上儿子一睡着，就用笔记本电脑学习。所以这绝对是精疲力竭的，而且我相信这本不需要那么困难。如果那个人能更友善并支持我，那么我觉得我不仅能更快地成为一名合格的心理学家，而且会更享受这个过程。而对我来说，这个过程并不愉快。直到最近三四年，也就是我获得资格后，我才开始享受生活。是的，我想如果人们正在观看或收听这一集，并且他们想，好吧，接下来该怎么办？
I think I'm right in saying that it's kind of dependent on where people live. So there might be local charities that are supporting teenage mothers and their families and their children. But actually, there's a provision in local councils called Early Help, which is not the same as kind of children in need and having to be involved. involved and probably like any areas, some of the early help departments are better than others, but they might well be able to signpost you to other relevant agencies. Is that right? Yes, absolutely. Please have a look what's in your local area and it's also worth looking out to see if there are any children's centres in your area. There are still some short start centres around. Again, it is very much dependent on where you live in the country, but there is
我想我说得对，这在某种程度上取决于人们居住的地方。可能有一些当地的慈善机构支持未成年母亲及其家庭和孩子。但实际上，地方议会有一项名为“早期帮助”（Early Help）的规定，这与“需要帮助的儿童”（children in need）以及必须介入的情况不同。和任何领域一样，一些早期帮助部门比其他部门做得更好，但他们很可能能够为你指引其他相关机构。是这样吗？是的，绝对是。请查看你当地的情况，也值得看看你所在地区是否有任何儿童中心。仍然有一些“确保开端”（Sure Start）中心存在。同样，这在很大程度上取决于你居住在国家的哪个地方，但确实有
support out there. You just have to sometimes dig a little bit to find it. Thank you so much. Where can people learn more about you and your work, Dr. Hayley. So I have a website that people can access, which is lugassi learning solutions.com. So that's where they can find out a bit more about the work that I do as an educational psychologist, as well as the public speaking and training support that I offer to schools and organisations. Amazing.
支持存在。你有时只需要稍微挖掘一下就能找到。非常感谢。人们可以在哪里了解更多关于你和你的工作，Hayley博士？我有一个网站，人们可以访问，即lugassylearningsolutions.com。在那里他们可以更多地了解我作为教育心理学家的工作，以及我为学校和组织提供的公开演讲和培训支持。太棒了。
If anyone's listening to this and wondering how we spell Lagasy, it's Lugase, it's L-U-G-A-S-S-Y. But all of the details will be in the show notes and in the description. Haley, thank you so much for the work that you do. I'm so pleased that ultimately it's had a lovely outcome for you and your family. And well done on the incredible work you do as a qualified educational psychologist too. Thank you so much for your time. Thank you. I love my chat with Dr. Haley and I hope you did too.
如果有人在听这个节目并想知道Lagasy怎么拼写，是Lugase，L-U-G-A-S-S-Y。但所有详细信息都会在节目笔记和描述中。Hayley，非常感谢你所做的工作。我很高兴最终这对你和你的家人来说有一个美好的结果。也祝贺你作为一名合格的教育心理学家所做的出色工作。非常感谢你的时间。谢谢。我很喜欢与Hayley博士的这次谈话，希望你也一样。
If you did, please do let us know in the comments, either on YouTube or on Spotify, what you thought to the episode. You can also reach out to me wherever you are on social media where I'm Dr. Marianne I would love it if you would start sharing your favourite episodes to your social media stories and accounts and tag me, Dr. Marianne Trent, and I would love to get to know you there. Has Dr. Haley's story inspired you? I do hope so. I hope that we're beginning to shape and change the narrative and I would love to know your opinion.
如果你喜欢，请在YouTube或Spotify的评论区告诉我们你对这一集的看法。你也可以在社交媒体上随时联系我，我是Marianne博士。如果你能开始在你的社交媒体故事和账户中分享你最喜欢的剧集并标记我，Marianne Trent博士，我会非常高兴，我也很想在那里认识你。Hayley博士的故事激励了你吗？我真心希望如此。我希望我们开始塑造和改变叙事方式，我很想知道你的意见。
If you are an aspiring psychologist and you're looking to get your foot in the door to be able to think about all things psychology and the types of things, conversations psychologists have, please do consider joining the aspiring psychologist membership, which you can do from just £30 a month with no minimum term. Head to www.uspiring-psychologist.com UK. If you're a really big fan of the show and of me as a creator, you can also join my paid podcast membership community, which you can do on YouTube, you can do on Apple Podcasts, and directly through Captivate. You can get exclusive subscriber-only content and early access to the podcast too. Check out all the details in the show notes. Thank you so much for being here. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
如果你是一位有抱负的心理学家，并且正在寻找机会进入这个行业，能够思考心理学的所有事物以及心理学家进行的对话类型，请考虑加入“有抱负的心理学家会员”（Aspiring Psychologist Membership），每月仅需30英镑，没有最低期限。前往www.aspiring-psychologist.com/uk。如果你是该节目和我作为创作者的忠实粉丝，你也可以加入我的付费播客会员社区，你可以在YouTube、Apple Podcasts上加入，也可以直接通过Captivate加入。你可以获得独家的订阅者专享内容，并提前收听播客。查看节目笔记中的所有详细信息。非常感谢你的收听。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。